[Music]
my dearest dolly because I am riding in
my bed
this won't be so terribly neat but
nevermind I'll just go on scrolling for
Donnie is interested in it all the same
[Music]
hello and welcome back to another video
if you thought me going through
Einsteins grades was an invasion of his
privacy well the worst was yet to come
today as was highly requested I'm going
to be going through Einsteins love
letters
now the originals are all referenced in
the description
these ones I printed out myself onto
some tea stained paper and well they're
pretty spicy they show that Einstein
struggled with some of the same problems
and relationships and love that many
people do and they also show that at
times
Einstein's mind was lost in space
thinking about physics but at other
times his mind was lost in love so let's
have a look at them Einstein met his
first wife Mileva while they were both
students at university but that is not
where this story starts no we are
starting with Einsteins high-school
romance a girl called Marie event Ola
beloved sweetheart many many thanks
sweetheart for your charming little
letter which made me endlessly happy it
is so wonderful to be able to press to
one's heart such a bit of paper which
too so dear little eyes have lovingly
beheld only now do I realize how
indispensable my dear little sunshine
has become to my happiness
my mother has also taken you to her
heart even though she does not know you
we can see that Einsteins mother did
approve of this little relationship
because she signed the bottom of the
slitter herself without having rid the
litter
I send you cordial greetings from
Pauline Einstein this approval becomes
relevant later on when things turn a
little sour and the families no longer
like each other that
much this girl Marie is someone who is
tine met while he was studying at the
our our school in Switzerland Einstein
actually lodged with Marie's family as
her father was a professor at the school
and this litter was written while
Einstein was back in his own hometown
for the holidays here's a reply from
Marie a loved sweetheart your little
basket arrived today and in vain did I
strain my eyes looking for a little note
even though the mere sight of your dear
handwriting in the address was enough to
make me happy it finishes off with all I
can say is that I love you for all
eternity sweetheart and may god preserve
and protect you a spoiler eternity
didn't last for quite as long as they
thought fast forward about a year and we
have a letter written from Einstein to
Pauline Lynn Toler and that is Marie's
mother it's addressed dear mommy which
is a little confusing some Einsteins
mother's name is also Pauline but this
is him writing to his girlfriend's
mother and it's not the nicest of
letters in fact it's almost a bit of a
breakup note I am writing you so soon in
order to cut short an inner struggle
whose outcome is in fact already firmly
settled in my mind I cannot come to
visit you at Whitsuntide this must have
been some invitation for Einstein to joy
in the family somewhere he speaks about
pain which he has brought her child pain
that was brought through his
thoughtlessness and ignorance of her
delicate nature so the sounds like
they've freshly broken up and Einstein
is cutting ties with the family there's
an interesting sentence here as he goes
on to describe what he's up to and he
says that strenuous intellectual work
and looking at God's nature are there
reconciling fortifying yet relentlessly
strict angel
that shall lead me through all of life's
troubles this letter was May 1897 and by
February 1898 we have the first litter
that I'll show here addressed to Mileva
Maric maleva was a classmate of
Einsteins at ETH she was the only female
there studying physics and at the time
of this letter she was actually away
from Zurich and she was in Heidelberg
pursuing some of her studies there
Einstein says that he is very happy
about her intention to continue her
studies here again and he's referring to
ETH he also goes on to tell her about
some of the material they've covered and
he mentions the infamous Weber who
lectured on heat now if you've seen my
video on Einsteins grades you will know
that Weber is a little notorious they
didn't in their relationship on good
terms it's now 1899 we have another
letter here to maleva this is one that
highlights the fact that they used to
study together a lot he says when I was
reading Helmholtz for the first time it
seemed inconceivable that you were not
here with me and now it's not much
better so it seems that Einstein really
does enjoy her company on the other hand
he makes a note here about his family
who he kind of finds a bit narrow-minded
he's struggling to relate with them
anymore it is strange how a way of life
will eventually change us and all the
nuances of our soul deep inside we
become so incomprehensible to each other
that we are unable to actively empathize
with the other and feel what moves the
other Albert finds in maleva something
that he can't find in his family which
is sort of an intellectual equal
someone who he can discuss Helmholtz
with perhaps that is why Albert is so
attracted to her she is a couple of
years older than him and probably quite
mature probably a lot more so there
Albert found in his first relationship
with Marie here's another letter from
maleva
she says all this time I have not gotten
further than our garden we now don't go
to town at all there have been many
cases of scarlet fever and furia so that
we prefer staying in our own fresh and
healthy air so it shows that lock down
vibes are nothing new at the bottom of
this video you can see some of the
nicknames that these two used referring
to each other this one is signed off
your doctor which is the name for dolly
here's another letter from Einstein and
in it he tells me later that her letters
always make him so happy
that everybody teases him for it he also
goes on to mention that his sister is
following in his footsteps by moving to
our how to complete her high school
education he takes it upon himself to
mention the little daughter there who he
fell so terribly in love with four years
ago and here he is referring to Marie
I'm not quite sure why he says this but
he then says if I saw the girl again a
few times I would surely get crazy again
I am aware of that and fear it like fire
maybe something got lost in translation
but it seems like Einstein is telling
his current love interest that he's at
risk of falling back in love with his ex
he is a short and sweet note from maleva
addressed to one of her pet names for
Albert Johan zl-- and she says since I
like you so much and you are so far away
that I cannot give you a kiss I am now
writing this little letter and I'm
asking you whether you like me as much
as I do you answer me immediately
thousand kisses from your doctor Albert
and Malaya's marriage did end in divorce
but these letters show us that in the
in-between
and at the start of their relationship
there was very much a lot of affection
between the two we then have the poem to
maleva which was written in bed and
under it some more disapproval from
Einstein's mum I go into Mama's room
first I have to tell her about the
examination then she asked me innocently
so what will become of dolly my wife say
I equally innocently but prepared for a
real scene this then ensued immediately
mama threw herself on the bed buried her
head in the pillow and cried like a
child after she had recovered from the
initial shock she immediately switched
to a desperate offensive you are ruining
your future and blocking your path
through life that woman cannot gain
entrance to a decent family it seems
that Einsteins mum disapproved of this
relationship because she thought that
Einstein was too young to marry and
settle down he was about 21 at the time
she thought he was throwing away his
career prospects she also didn't
consider maleva to be very beautiful at
this time where a woman could be either
beautiful or smart Einstein's mom makes
remarks about maleva being a smart one
but as we know Albert was a very
independent person and three years after
this letter Albert and maleva did go on
to get married and they had some
children together he also mentions how
he feels Restless without maleva in his
presence he says when I do not have you
I feel as if I were not home when I am
sitting I would like to walk when I am
walking I look forward to being at home
when I amuse myself I would like to
study and when I am studying I feel a
lack of contemplative nough Sandra posed
when I go to bed I am not satisfied with
how I passed the day I like this passage
here because it really shows the human
aspect of Einstein and the fact that yes
his
mind was on all things physics and
thinking of some of the biggest ideas
there are but his mind was also in love
and he's feeling lovesick and he can't
focus and that's you know a side of
Einstein that you never hear about now
if you remember back to the first letter
we had Einstein's mum Pauline giving a
glowing review to his first girlfriend
Marie Vint Allah although that is long
in the past now and in fact this is a
very nasty note written from Pauline
Einstein to Pauline Vint Allah when
talking about Marie she says that we
don't want anything to do with her there
is constant friction with Albert because
of it now these families are still
linked together because I believe in
Stein's younger sister Maya went to our
AO and also bordered with the family
in fact Mayer goes on to marry Marie's
brother Paul and becomes Maya
Vint Allah although in this letter
Einsteins mom says that we should not
talk anywhere about an engagement this
miss Marie is causing me the bitterest
hours of my life if it were in my power
I would make every possible effort to
banish her from our horizon I really
dislike her but I have lost every
influence on Albert you can imagine
therefore our professor how unhappy this
makes me Pauline Einstein not sure
totally what is going on here whether
Albert is still seeing Marie in some way
but definitely these families are no
longer on good terms although they are
forever linked thanks to Maya and poor
while we're on the topic of hate let's
fast forward a few years to 1912 this is
after Einsteins miracle year of
productivity which was in 1905 and here
we have a litter to Elsa Rosenthal who
was actually Einsteins
cousin now yes Einstein does go on to
marry Elsa she becomes his second wife
after he divorces maleva but him and
Malaya are still together when this
letter was written they didn't divorce
until 1919 Einstein says to Elsa that I
can't even begin to tell you how fond I
have become of you during these days he
also that mentions that he had some kind
of fleeting crush on Elsa's sister Paula
but P assures her that is over now he
says when I think of the bad
relationship between my wife and Mya his
sister or my mother then I must admit to
myself sadly that I find all three of
them quite unlikable but I have to have
someone to love otherwise life is
miserable and this someone is you you
cannot do anything about it since I'm
not asking you for permission I am the
absolute ruler in the netherworld of my
imagination or at least that is what I
choose to think now I don't find that
sentence too romantic but it must have
worked out for them kisses from your
Elbert this letter ends with a spicy PS
which is him saying if this is what you
want then write me again I will always
destroy the letters as you have
requested
I have already destroyed the first one
so I think they knew that this
relationship of theirs was not going to
be well-received
and that they were in their best
interest to keep it secret
dearest Elsie I am writing so late
because I have misgivings about our fair
I have the feeling that it will not be
good for the two of us as well as for
the others if we form a closer
attachment so I am writing to you today
for the last time this breakup letter of
sorts with Elsie while he's still
married to maleva shows how heartbroken
Einstein is to be cutting off this
relationship but never fear next year in
19:13 things are back on I'm Stein says
now we will be together and will rejoice
in each other unfortunately this won't
happen until the end of the winter
semester because I could not bring
myself to break off things here so
rapidly give my regards to uncle and
aunt here he must be referring to his
uncle and aunt which is Elsa's parents
certainly a taboo relationship now and
I'm not sure to what extent it was then
this next letter from 1914 showed some
of the friction that the relationship
faced dear Elsa didn't I tell you that
all hell would break loose he refers to
maleva as Meza and says that she is by
nature unfriendly and mistrustful he
says you showed her kindness but she
obviously distrusts you now that doesn't
seem surprising to me seeing as this
Elsa character is about to steal her
husband away this next letter I really
wanted to show you it's written a month
later to Elsa and Einstein is
apologizing for being a poor letter
writer he says I cannot find the time to
write because I am occupied with truly
great things
day and night I rack my brain in an
effort to penetrate more deeply into the
things that I gradually discovered in
the past two years and that represent an
unprecedented advance in the fundamental
problem of physics I think this is a
nice insight into Einstein's opinions of
his own work he says that he must now
write a long article since his most
distinguished colleagues refused to
accept his point of view
Einstein did have to put in a lot of
effort to convince other physicists of
his work and I think this is a fitting
final letter to show it again reminds us
that Einsteins life is interwoven with
love life and physics you can't really
separate his correspondence with any of
these girls and has
session worth working on figuring out
some of these fundamental ideas at his
most excited times he is talking to
these girls about his findings or
discussing his studies I hope you have
enjoyed this little insight into an
aspect of Einsteins life that you don't
often see it took me a long time to your
research and edit this video because I
wanted to make sure I was bringing you
the spiciest litters and there was a lot
to read through on the digital archive I
was only able to devote this time thanks
to the viewers who support me on patreon
it is their support that keeps the
channel running so if you would like to
show any appreciation for the videos I
make please consider supporting the
channel there as well
the link will be on screen and down in
the description I'd like to give a big
thanks to all of my current patrons
including a special mention for today's
patreon cat of the day and achi thanks
for watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]